well brian as more get vaccinated and
cases decrease
you can already see the change in las
vegas we are on the road to recovery but
how long could it take 8 news now
reporter sally jaramillo
joining us now live near the strip and
sally i know that you spoke with
visitors on how they're feeling when
they come out to visit las vegas but you
also talk to some experts
about the recovery rate which right now
is about to 60 percent right
yeah denise the properties on the strip
operating 24 7
and capacity limits increasing the many
people i spoke to today tell me
they're accompanying that our economy
will rebuild back by the end of this
year and experts say we are heading
in the right direction we are happy like
finally everything is opening up
so that's a good thing vegas has been
great
um they're starting like i say with them
opening up the stores or the
different uh scenery again is
awesome this is a function of science
it's not a function of time and right
now the science seems to be
more on our side than at any point
before principal analyst jeremy aguero
says with a vaccine here
and hospital capacity down we are seeing
changes in our economy
and more jobs added as we get into
summer the expectation is our tourism
industry starts to pick up a little bit
more
stephen miller professor of economics at
unlv agrees
there is pent up demand for people to
have a good time and take some time off
have a vacation
you start to look into the fall we start
thinking about the fact that we just had
a golden knights game that had some fans
and that's going to increase
along with raider games and conventions
i think we're going to plateau
a little bit as our economy really seeks
to establish a new equilibrium
a new normal although there is
excitement to return to
normalcy we still need to be cautious
and the question is are we going to go
too far too fast
and will the new variants sort of throw
us a curveball
and while there is a new sense of
feeling of energy and positivity right
now the pandemic is not over yet and
expect there to be
specific restrictions still for several
months to come
reporting live near the strip sally
caramillo 8 news now